bonjour d'anyama d'un jour merci
beaucoup d'être notre invité politique
ce matin vous êtes député de l'eure
président du groupe l'est républicain à
l'assemblée nationale on est ensemble
pendant 20 minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse quotidienne
régionale représenté par christelle
bertrand du groupe la dépêche bonjour
cristal jour oriane bonjour très bien
les jours on commence par la crise
sanitaire damien abad près de 60000 cas
quotidiens donc été recensés hier c'est
du jamais vu depuis un an et pour ton
jean castex quand il a pris la parole
lundi soir il n'a pas annoncé de mesures
de restriction excepté un renforcement
du protocole à l'école et la fermeture
des discothèques le gouvernement qui
fait donc le choix de ne pas serrer la
vis il a raison oui parce que
effectivement la circulation du virus
est importante mais ce qu'il faut
regarder c'est le nombre de personnes en
réanimation et aujourd'hui on a trois
quatre fois moins une personne qu'on
avait en mars dernier et donc la réalité
c'est que on n'a pas confiné à prendre
des mesures de couvre-feu de restriction
de liberté pour les français tant que
l'on n'a effectivement pas
d'augmentation en réanimation mais
l'enjeu aujourd'hui c'est quoi c'est
surtout la troisième dose c'est surtout
le rappelle est donc ouvrir des centres
de vaccination sur les territoires avoir
suffisamment de doses et accélérer le
processus pour que à noël au moment où
on va tous se retrouver en famille on
puisse avoir un maximum de personnes
d'abord il ya aujourd'hui un déficit de
tests antigénique ce qui pose une
difficulté sur le dépistage pour les
enfants et pour les cas asymptomatiques
ensuite on constate aussi qu'il ya eu et
j'espère que ça va cela est en train de
se corriger mais un manque de de
certains de doses mais surtout c'est le
déploiement des centres de vaccination
et là moi je lance le crid alerte c'est
sur le déploiement sur le territoire
centres de vaccination et surtout du
manque de personnel parce que la réalité
aujourd'hui c'est que si on n'ouvre pas
suffisamment cessantes c'est parce qu'on
est déficit de personnel et parce que
c'est très difficile tout simplement de
répondre à la fois aux besoins d'urgence
dans l'hôpital public aux soins
quotidiens et en même temps de répondre
à cette exigence de vaccination alors
vous dites les services de réanimation
ne sont pas plaint pourtant on discute
de la vaccination des moins de 12 ans
aurait un pause le masque à l'école
est-ce que ça s'est justifié selon vous
bon le masque à l'école il a déjà était
été fait dans les cours de récré colas
création et va encore un espace de
liberté là en moi je suis je suis pro
vaccin 1 mais j'ai des réserves je vous
le dis sur la question de la vaccination
des enfants parce que je crois que le
bilan coût avantage à ce stade en tout
cas n'est pas favorable et donc il vaut
mieux sauver les deux coups bas écoutez
d'abord parce que moi je pense que sur
les enfants aujourd'hui on voit bien il
n'y a pas de quasiment pas ou pas de
forme grave et que donc forcément ça
interroge aussi tous les parents moi je
dis le débat il doit être sur le fait
les non-vaccinés des personnes adultes
et donc c'est pas parce que le
gouvernement n'arrive pas à convaincre
des millions de français à se faire
vacciner qu'on doit des portes et
finalement cela sur les enfants audits
ont fait on vaccine les enfants parce
que des adultes ne veulent pas stable
parce qu'on vaccine des enfants pour ben
oui parce qu'on vacciner enfants parce
qu'à une contamination divers une
circulation pardon du virus qui est
importante et on sait qu'ils sont
vecteurs de circulation donc la réalité
et quand on regarde les statistiques
dans les réanimations on a quasiment
quasiment que des personnes non
vaccinées donc l'enjeu pense que le
l'effort du gouvernement devrait d'abord
et avant tout se concentrer sur la
vaccination de toutes celles et tous
ceux qui ne sont qui n'ont pas été
vaccinés et plutôt que de se poser la
question de la vaccination obligatoire
des enfants sur lesquels j'ai en tout
cas à titre personnel un certain nombre
de réserves
la base du volontariat c'est pas gênant
mais on le sait bien mais il faut pas là
commencé en décembre non mais attendez
sur la base du volontariat chaque parent
prend ses responsabilités j'ai aucune
difficulté avec ça on sait très bien
comment ça commence la réalité
aujourd'hui c'est que la question qu'il
faut se poser c'est que c'est que c'est
sur la vie etc 6 nations oblige
obligatoire des adultes ou en tout cas
la question de la vaccination des
adultes qui ne sont pas convaincus parce
que aujourd'hui à la vaccination
obligatoire moi je en tout cas si je
devais choisir si je devais choisir
entre la vaccination obligatoire des
adultes et la vaccination de tous les
enfants je préfère la vaccination
obligatoire des adultes alors même que
on commence à dire que peut-être au
micron n'est pas sensible à cette
vaccination alors on n'est pas un moment
un peu compliqué l'enjeu aussi pour nous
c'est l'efficacité des vaccins on voit
bien on a eu tout un débat sur la
question la vérité c'est que c'est sur
l'efficacité de cette fixité des vaccins
aujourd'hui on voit bien que toutes
celles et tous ceux qui ont fait la
troisième dose on un taux de protection
beaucoup plus important et que donc
aujourd'hui le vaccin et notamment le
rappel troisième dose à une efficacité
certaine donc l'état sur le delta pour
moi avoir ensuite effectivement sur le
chemin de nouveaux variants il ya aussi
des recherches qui continue en parallèle
là dessus mais on le voit bien tant que
nous avons quasiment que des non
vaccinés en réanimation tant que les
formes graves au que le vaccin protège
des formes graves il faut de toute façon
accélérée la vaccination et notamment
pour les publics fragiles il ya encore
beaucoup de personnes âgées qui ne sont
pas vaccinés et que là il ya un enjeu de
société extrêmement important
a
décidé d'annuler son grand meeting prévu
samedi pour lancer sa campagne c'est
uniquement des raisons sanitaires où il
attend aussi une volonté politique
d'imprimer sa marque sur cette campagne
n'ont cessé que les pécresse depuis le
début elle a fait le show de la
protection des français et d'ailleurs si
elle s'engage dans cette élection
présidentielle c'est pour protéger son
peuple pour protéger les français et que
donc elle sera vigilante par rapport à
la question de la crise sanitaire elle
sera vigilante à double titre vis-à-vis
du pouvoir quand on utilisera la crise
sanitaire à des fins politiques pour
empêcher le débat démocratique mais
vigilante également et surtout à l'égard
de la protection des français et que
quand vous avez une circulation du virus
qui est importante et bien forcément un
meeting s'il ya un risque certain réel
qui est là et donc je pense qu'elle a
pris la bonne décision que de reporter
ce congrès à un moment où le sait il ya
une circulation importante de demande
des efforts aux français les français ne
comprendraient pas que les politiques
eux-mêmes s'exonère des efforts qu'on
leur demande comme d'autres le font jean
luc mélenchon est réellement tenu des
meetings ce week end à nago tiendra un
meeting à perpignan dimanche ils ont
tant pour vous savez sauf que nous on a
une responsabilité c'est qu'on est un
parti de gouvernement est-ce qu'on n'est
pas les extrêmes
je parle pas de niveau mais en tout cas
des extrêmes en tant que tel et parler
de monsieur mélenchon et ou encore
monsieur zemmour qui a fait son meeting
ne sent pas sanitaire quasiment sans
masque ou la réalité c'est que c'est que
tout le monde s'en moque mais ce qu'on a
nous je sais qu on nous reprochera
beaucoup plus cela que à eux en tant que
tel c'est injuste mais c'est la réalité
de la situation nous on doit être en
responsabilité
l'objectif de valérie pécresse c'est pas
de faire un beau score c'est de gagner
cette élection présidentielle et donc
d'avoir une crédibilité politique et
donc c'est très important que dans cette
crise sanitaire et bien sa priorité ça
sur la protection des français elle est
venue devant les parlementaires hier
vous a dit d'abord de mettre de
l'enthousiasmé de l'énergie du dynamisme
d'y croire d'avoir la pêche parce que ça
c'est un point important
ensuite conçoit ses relais locaux parce
que c'est important que sur les
territoires puissent s'étendre on est le
premier parti d'opposition à l'assemblée
nationale nous sommes ici majoritaire au
sénat nous avons une majorité d'élus
locaux dans les départements dans les
régions donc si tout le monde s'y met si
tout le monde chance en meute et si
cette france des territoires de droite
se lève pour valérie pécresse alors oui
on peut gagner cette élection
présidentielle et c'est ça le message
politique est ne fait pas cesser c'est
qu'elle a besoin de nous et qu'il a
besoin de mobiliser ses forces sur le
terrain ça vous a parlé des premières
réformes qu'a mettre en oeuvre vous êtes
des parlementaires on imagine qu'elle
vous prépare si jamais
ça veut dire que vous commencerez tout
de suite que des réformes sont prêtes
quelles sont ses priorités oui c'est un
point qui a été très appréciée par les
parlementaires c'est que elle a autant
parlé de l'exercice du pouvoir que de la
conquête du pouvoir on voit bien que son
enjeu c'est de faire et pas de plaire et
que donc son objectif politique qui est
le nôtre aussi c'est d'agir dans les
trois premiers mois de manière forte
donc ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
qu'il faut qu'on soit prêt et nous
allons à l'assemblée nationale préparez
un certain nombre de propositions de
lois de manière comme j'imagine au sénat
de manière à ce que si demain nous
sommes en responsabilité nous sommes
élus et bien on puisse agir tout de
suite sur ce sujet parce que les
français en ont assez des amateurs et
ils veulent des professionnels
aujourd'hui en politique mais bien sur
des sujets très concrets d'abord la
réforme conditionnelle vous savez
qu'elle a pris d'engagement sur le débat
migrateurs notamment pour voter à des
quotas sur les sujets économiques
également de manière très concrète
notamment les engagements qu'elle a pris
pour approcher le salaire net du salaire
brut et augmenter en tout cas des 10%
des salaires sur des sujets aussi de
réformes sociales sur la réforme des
retraites
bien sûr qu'il faut agir aussi
rapidement sur ces sujets là on le sait
d'anciens un quinquennat qui est un
temps très court dans la vie politique
française les six premiers mois sont
absolument déterminant il ya ceux qui
sont prêts et à ceux qui n'ont jamais
été prêt et qu'ils ne sont jamais la
vérité c'est que nous on veut montrer
qu'on est des professionnels que nous
sommes prêts et que nous attachons
autant d'importance à l'exercice qu'à la
conquête du pouvoir ça veut dire pas de
vacances d'été mais ça veut dire les
parlementaires tenir nos engagements
oui mais ça c'est normal s'il n'y a pas
de sujet là dessus c'est tenir nos
engagements et exécuter le programme et
tenir nos promesses parce que sinon les
français c'est comme ça qui nous prend
alors elle vous a demandé de l'
enthousiasme
un sondage est sorti hier qui a dû vous
en donner de l' enthousiasme
ll battrait manuel macro second tour
qu'est ce que vous en pensez de ce
sondage comment vous l'analysez d'abord
c'est une bonne nouvelle c'est la preuve
c'est pour moi un un double aspect
positif d'abord c'est le symbole de la
réussite de ce congrès quand ça se passe
bien avant et pendant ça se passe
toujours mieux après la réussite du
congrès le fait que tous les candidats
aient joué et ai vraiment respectée avec
du jeu et permettez moi ici d'avoir de
saluer l'attitude notamment de gerry
bertrand qui a été une attitude digne et
responsable dans la défaite et qui a
soutenu dans la minute même valérie
pécresse et qui pour pour la faire
gagner
ça ça nous a aidés ce congrès qui se
passe bien et ensuite il ya un effet
dynamique personnelle aussi de valérie
pécresse je pense qu'il ya une nouveauté
est le fait que ce soit une femme
candidate à droite le fait qu'elle soit
président de la première région de
france que elle a aussi une patte
personnelle sur les questions
d'éducation d'environnement de famille
donc l'aspect à la fois congrès réussi
dynamique collective plus sa patte
personnelle fait qu'effectivement il
monte dans les sondages maintenant il
faut il faut rester humble parce que il
faut confirmer ces sondages là dans le
temps ça me doutais que ça soit juste un
effet primaires c'est pas non non je
crois pas je pense qu'on peut installer
le match mais l'enjeu pour nous c'est de
durer et de stabiliser ces sondages là
pour installer le match et montrer que
la droite allait dans le match et qu'on
va faire ce match et avec emmanuel
macron et avec les extrêmes et que le
pacs qui entre le maquereau nice mais
les extrémismes eh bien on va leur en
trombe à le casser il ya un pacte tacite
parce que la vérité on sait bien
pourquoi parce que c'est la meilleure
monsieur zemmour et même le pen sur les
deux meilleures assurances vie à la
réflexion des manuels macron tout le
monde le sait d'ailleurs le sondage
deuxième tour est intéressant il montre
quoi c'est que seule valérie pécresse et
seule la droite républicaine peuvent
battre emmanuel macron second tour
est-ce que ce résultat elle le doit à
cette alliance avec eric ciotti qui
s'est noué dès les premiers je pense que
cette alliance était absolument
indispensable
eric soucier incarne une droite forte de
conviction avec des positions
courageuses que nous partageons
d'ailleurs sur beaucoup de sujets
régaliens sur l'autorité de l'état sur
l'immigration ces sont des positions de
thé reprise aussi au groupe je veux
saluer aussi à l'esprit de
responsabilité d'eric ciotti qui a su
aussi capter un électorat qui pouvaient
partir chez monsieur zemmour ou chez
madame le pen est donc bien sûr ça veut
dire qu'il peut pour vous écouter en
tout cas le fait qu'ils aient cet accord
là le fait que le premier déplacement de
valérie pécresse soit été effectuées
chez eric ciotti le fait qu'eric ciotti
lui même a dit je soutient valérie
pécresse sans condition le fait aussi
qu'on voit bien à 100 que l'émission en
tout cas c'est ce qu'il a dit il ya mes
soutiens en entier total bien sûr que
son rôle dans la campagne doit être
capitale parce que et je le lui aussi
nous sommes ensemble à l'assemblée
nationale et je sais une voix forte
aujourd'hui qui permet de capter me font
marcher sur ses deux jambes il yad'un
côté capter effectivement les toits qui
pourraient tenter par monsieur zemmour
notamment et de l'autre côté il faut du
sud m au disque qui ont voté françois
filon et qui ne sont pas encore tout
seul à même de vous savez il ya je pense
bruno retailleau incarne aussi ses
droits il peut en capter une partie
laurent wauquiez enfin il julien aubert
qui va s'avérer laurent wauquiez dans la
campagne bien sûr connaissent ailleurs
il sera dès vendredi avec il accueillera
valence vendredi valérie pécresse à lyon
à la suite de son déplacement chez
michel barnier en savoie donc salue
aujourd'hui tout le monde est sur le
pont tout le monde impliqué enfin on a
une force du collectif en fait en chasse
en meute pourvu que ça dure les légères
tensions qui a eu autour de l'idée à un
guantanamo à la française d'une priorité
nationale sur les emplois ça vous
inquiète non parce qu'en fait ça a été
le gode ce qui fait figure d'épouvantail
c'est le guantanamo la française mais
qu'est ce que ça veut dire c'est la
rétention de sûreté ça c'est un débat
technique politique la rétention de
sûreté que nous avons dans notre
programme d'ailleurs guillaume larrivé
qui soutient valérie pécresse et à poser
un certain nombre de points sur la
question de rétention de sûreté à
améliorer donc voilà je dis simplement
moi je ne veux pas qu'on ait des mots je
préfère qu'on ait l'action forte plutôt
que le verbe haut mais ce que vous
craignez pas des tensions permanentes
comme ça pendant la campagne entre eric
ciotti qui veut imposer son programme et
valérie pécresse qui n'est pas qu'ils
n'incarnent pas forcément cette ligne
peu logique chez vous c'est valérie
pécresse qui a gagné 6 cl qu'un poste se
gagner c'est son programme c'est pas une
question d'imposer c'est de le partager
de la riche hirko maladie de le pimenté
de la parle d'eux est ce que pour vous
ça l'est aussi de pâques deux est a
parlé également de piment depuis
pour elle si on l'entend ça doit être à
la marge a dit c'est mon programme qui a
gagné est ce que pendant que ça doit
être plus qu'à la marge ça est-ce
qu'elle doit tenir compte du gramme de
ses adversaires et modifier le sien pour
faire tenir compte mais valérie pécresse
elle doit surtout être elle-même vous
rendez compte que une fois élu si
l'elysée mais moi finalement mon
programme hop il va à la poubelle et non
ça ça fonctionne pas la réalité c'est
que c'est une question de crédibilité
politique c'est qu'il faut qu'elle soit
soi même il faut qu'elles portent les
sujets qu'elle a voulu porter depuis le
début il faut qu'elle incarne son
programme politique en visite alors
qu'elle parlait des questions
d'éducation de famille d'environnement
certainement mieux que tous les autres
aujourd'hui notre famille politique ça
serait quand même dommage de renoncer à
ces sujets là il faut on voit bien les
questions de la gaspillage d'argent
public du rétablissement des comptes
c'est un enjeu sur lequel elle a une
vraie sensibilité donc ainsi à des
sujets qui manquent par exemple xavier
bertrand collomb se tenir prêts nous a
parlé beaucoup de la république
mais bien sûr qu'elle va l'enrichir ya
deux points on parlait dé xavier
bertrand il ya deux points sur lesquels
moi je suis particulièrement attaché
dans le projet politique des années
bertrand c'est effectivement la
république des territoires la france des
territoires faut vraiment qu'on parle
aux territoires qu'on a un nouvel acte
de décentralisation
parce que la question d'un fracture
médical du numérique sont des enjeux
fondamentaux pour les français l'accès
aux services publics et puis la question
de la france des classes moyennes et des
classes populaires il faut pouvoir
parler du pouvoir d'achat des classes
moyennes et populaires ou savait qu'on
avait deux mesures importantes à la
xavier bertrand c'était une qui permet
de dire à la transe à partir la 35e
heures le net égal le brut et la prime
d'activité il faut qu'on aille sur ces
sujets là c'est extrêmement important et
vous souhaitez calais reprennent à ce
moment là je suis pas en train de dire
faut qu'elle reprendrait une telle
mesure c'est qu'il faut qu' il faut
qu'on parle assez à ces catégories là et
aussi au pouvoir d'achat des retraités
parce que les retraités ils ont été
abîmés pendant tout ce mandat avec les
hausse de csg avec la non d'inditex et
indexation des retraites sur l'inflation
avec une réforme des retraites qui était
injuste et inéquitable donc là aussi
donc en fait il s'agit pas pour moi je
suis pas en train de dire on va dire
mais prenez telles mesures telles
mesures telles mesures c'est de dire on
doit enrichir et être complémentaires
mais ce qu'elle est ce qu'elle est moins
audible auprès des classes populaires de
cette classe moyenne comme l'était
xavier bertrand est ce que là pour le
coup c'est lui qui peut parler à ce club
et moi je j'ai toujours pensé qu'il y
avait une vraie complémentarité entre
xavier bertrand et valérie pécresse
d'ailleurs il ya une très bonne entente
et une vraie complémentarité et je suis
certain que xavier bertrand de toute
façon elle va mettre toute son énergie
dans cette campagne nous voulons mettre
toute notre énergie pour qu'elle gagne
pour cause surtout la droite gagne et
que la france gagne l'un des
enseignements de ce sondage c'est que
malgré le très beau score de valérie
pécresse c'est qu'eric zemmour et marine
le pen continue à faire 30 % à eux deux
dans les sondages est-ce qu'il va aussi
falloir aller chercher ses électeurs
vous avez raison on dit souvent que
monsieur zemmour ont fait baisser madame
le pen c'est vrai mais ce qu'on oublie
de dire c'est qu'il élargit aussi le
champ de l'extrême droite et que ça
c'est un enjeu pour nous important s'est
il faut qu'on parle à tous les déçus à
tous les déclassés à cette france
périphérique qui se sent abandonnée qui
n'a plus de service public qui a le
sentiment qu'elle paie toujours tout cas
n'a jamais droit à rien donc oui il ya
bien sûr une partie cet électorat et
c'est notamment cette france des classes
moyennes et classes populaires à
laquelle il faut parler qui ont glissé
qui sont pas raciste ou extrémiste mais
qui ont glissé vers ce vote là parce
qu'ils sont déçus parce qu'ils sont en
colère et parce qu'ils ne croient plus à
la droite républicaine parce qu'elle les
a déçus c'est ça l'enjeu il a tenu un
meeting ce week end dimanche à
villepinte qui a été émaillée de pas mal
d'incidents qu'est ce que vous avez
pensé tout ça moi je d'abord je condamne
les violences comme les provocations
d'où qu'elles viennent la réalité
aujourd'hui c'est qu'on peut pas avoir
un débat politique dans la violence et
ça et moi je suis autant je violente
depuis quelques malheureuses et
malheureusement beaucoup trop
malheureusement beaucoup trop et voyez
monsieur zemmour moi je le combats sur
le terrain des idées mais je trouve
qu'il donne il a le droit d'exprimer ses
idées de la droite d'exprimer ses
convictions et que j'ai été un des
premiers je crois à droite a demandé à
avoir un débat avec lui parce qu'il faut
voir la confrontation d'idées la
démocratie la république c'est la
confrontation d'idées c'est pas la
violence la personne qui l'a agressée
semble être
un électeur voir un adhérent dlr est ce
qu'il faut l'exclure de toute façon
écoutez je pense que ça avec mes
christian jacot prendre cette
responsabilité là
oui bien sûr enfin je veux dire un
moment donné on peut pas
c'est que l'on connaît la réalité c'est
que on peut pas accepter la violence
d'où qu'elle vienne et on peut pas
accepter des prises à partie personne et
c'est vrai pour monsieur zemmour c'est
vrai pour le présent la brique emmanuel
macron ans que mais parfois l'été la
partie c'est vrai pour nos candidats est
ce que ça veut dire plus de sécurité
autour des candidats aujourd'hui très
voulait jamais ça oui mais bien sûr
qu'il faut plus de sécurité autour des
candidats mais il faut surtout du
respect qu est-ce que tous les jours
maintenant on constate des élus qui sont
tabassés qui sont menacés c'est
inadmissible le respect c'est compliqué
sur les sages à faire mais c'est déjà ça
pour moi ça commence à l'école
république parce que un élu ça se
respecte quand je vois on parle la
région auvergne rhône-alpes c'est le
maire de bron le maire de rillieux la
pape qui sont menacés de mort uniquement
parce que ici ils font leurs actions ils
agissent en responsabilité c'est pas
admissible donc il ya certainement des
choses à revoir sur la loi et
certainement des dépôts de plainte
systématique est la société mère de
france avec dany sneijder a dit qu'elle
se porterait désormais participent
régulièrement ya aussi un changement de
comportement à avoir une culture du
respect inculte et on est dans une
société on respecte plus le prof à
l'école on respecte plus les lui dans sa
ville on respecte personne et donc il la
question 1 aujourd'hui le majeur c'est
le respect de l'autorité compliqué
aujourd'hui pour un homme politique
d'aller sur le terrain emmanuel macron
signé aujourd'hui sur le terrain est-ce
qu'il a raison de retourner au contact
des français d'aller dans ces villes
moyennes dont vous disiez tout à l'heure
ce sont entre à dire la raison pas on
voit bien que on a un président en
campagne bon voilà ça c'est on sait cela
on sait aujourd'hui que il va se
déclarer le plus tard possible pour
rester et maxime ont pris dans la
publiquement que les français ne sont
pas dupes et qu'ils ont vu lille hier et
qui verront demain un président en
campagne en ce sens qu'elle attend
depuis longtemps mais j'ai pas pensé
s'il a tort ou à raison je dis
simplement pour des raisons de clarté de
transparence ça serait mieux ce serait
mon choix candidats comme ça au moins
les choses seraient claires devant les
français mais par contre ce traité la
question des villes moyennes allée
centrale parce qu'aujourd'hui c'est sont
celles qui tiennent la société française
et aujourd'hui on voit bien que son cv
loyal qui parfois so paupérise et
parfois se trouve déclassé et qui
parfois perdre des services publics ou
d'aménagement du territoire etc c'est
celle là aussi qu'il faut accompagner
demain il tient une conférence de presse
sur la présidence française de l'europe
qu'est ce que vous en attendez de cette
conférence de presse et de la présidence
- cela rejetant de cette présidence
française de l'union c'est que d'abord
que la france porte le flambeau de
l'europe qu'elle ne le fasse pas tout
toute seule avec ses partenaires
ça veut dire que je n'attends pas des
effets de manche j'attends pas des coups
de menton j'attends pas des guerres des
qu'est ce que vous attendez comme acte
concret donc un le pacte migratoires
l'europe elle doit résoudre la question
des flux migratoires je me souviens de
la présidence française l'union
européenne nicolas sarkozy il y avait le
paquet immigrés asile immigration il
faut mettre ce sujet là en numéro 1 sur
la table deuxièmement le défi climatique
c'est un défi majeur en porter ses
paquets migrateurs et bien vous dire
d'abord que les frontières extérieures
de l'union c'est à dire qu'on ont
réaffirmé frontières effet de l'union on
est un convergence des politiques
d'asile également qu'on puisse
travailler à des hotspots notamment pour
que l'on puisse mieux géré en externe
etc autant on se met d'accord sur un
certain et les quotas ne pourra pas les
faire accepter par tous les pays
d'europe mais il faut qu'on ait des
frontières extérieures de l'union qui
soit ferme qui soit étanche et sur
lequel on a une vraie convergence c'est
aussi schengen sont tous sujets là
ensuite pour moi la politique migratoire
elle est nationale sur la sur la
question des quotas migratoires ça c'est
des chaque et à la responsabilité mais
qu'est ce qui se passe aujourd'hui sur
les deux demandes d'asile ce que je veux
pas c'est qu'on a une espèce de dumping
migratoires c'est à dire pas rien ce qui
se passe ce qui s'est passé à calais
c'est à dire la divise les différences
entre la grande bretagne est sortie
aujourd'hui de l'europe et la france
mais c'est ça qu'il faut voir donc oui
ça le climat également
sur l'immigration voté chaque année par
le parlement comment vous il faut des
quotas
bien sûr sur chaque type d'immigration
et et troisième axe pour moi la
présidence française ça doit être aussi
la question de la réciprocité dans les
échanges c'est à dire protéger notre
industrie et notre agriculture donc les
trois ans je sais le débat migratoire la
politique environnement et la prod
environnementale pardon et la protection
de l'agriculture de l'industrie dernier
mot sur l'équipement pour finir le texte
de loi sur les vg qui a été voté à
l'assemblée nationale ne devait pas être
étudié au sénat il le sera physique ble
ment finalement à la demande du
gouvernement vous pensez que c'est une
bonne chose écoutez moi je pense que
c'est toujours bien quand on a le débat
la réalité c'est que nous nous sommes
attachés à la loi simone veil il s'agit
pas de refaire le débat pour ou contre
ivg ça n'a pas de sens c'est pas ça le
sujet d'ailleurs tous les scénarios 10
il ya deux choses il est question la
clause de conscience et la question
effectivement la prolongation du délai
de douze à quatorze semaines je pense
qu'il faut trouver le bon équilibre dont
chloé les débats oui mais je pense que
le gouvernement lui-même d'apprécier
compris a beaucoup de réserves sur cette
prolongation pas du délai en tant que
tel ce qu'il faut surtout corriger et
c'est aussi là remettant sait qu'ils
vont beaucoup vrij essais sont surtout
les inéquités entre les territoires et
les inégalités territoriales et là je
pense qu'on peut effectivement amélioré
les choses effectivement des réticences
au gouvernement chez emmanuel macron et
il n'est pas forcément favorable à ce
texte sauf quand le remettant janvier au
sénat c'est la droite sénatoriale
connaissez piège politique fin sauf
qu'on la fait pas gérard larcher la
réalité c'est que gérard larcher il a
déjà évité le piège de la réforme
concessionnels j'ai fais toute confiance
pour gérer ce débat de la manière la
plus forte possible et si emmanuel
macron pense qu'à chaque fois il va
faire des coups politiques au sénat avec
gérard larcher président je souhaite
beaucoup de courage merci
[Musique]